of the world's natural resources water
is perhaps the most important
we can't live without it but as
temperatures increase in some places
around the world
it simply disappears future water wars
will likely eclipse current issues and
future water wars
could tear the world apart and there are
signs it's beginning
[Music]
these farmers have taken over a dam from
mexico's national guard
it's a coordinated city it's already
been violent
one female farmer was shot dead by the
gods
chihuahua state is one of the richest
farming areas in mexico
an industry dependent on its waterways
and dams
but the government has to pay a water
debt to the united states
to do that they need to drain la bakiya
down
and send it to the united states
it's actually a reasonable treaty for
mexico it's just not good for chihuahua
the 20 000 farmers here say the water
is according to the water treaty legally
theirs
jorge gutierrez is one of the farmers in
the surprising
uprising he says they won't budge
all the farmers you can see back
back down there which depends
from this water 20 20 000 families
and it's a huge mistake from government
mexican government to stolen
this water from us because
this dam is not for that reason
the national guard supported by the army
have taken over
surrounding dams and control points that
direct the water
across the border to texas
this is an unprecedented show of force
for an issue
that's gone on for years the 70 year old
treaty sees mexico and america sharing
this precious resource but the
temperature has changed
and there's less water so both sides
are preparing for a potential fight
the lucrative pecan nut harvest which
will be entirely exported to the united
states is underway
corgae and his colleagues employ
thousands of people to work the farms
without huge amounts of water none of
this would exist
without the water in the dam the farms
will die in the heat
they're appealing to the president to
break the impasse
and avoid more violence we make a
mexican
president responsible because
he is and he is the the power to stop
this
only him we are not criminals
just farmers we come to work
it's all we need water for world
the fact is that mexico does owe america
the water
and it seems the government doesn't want
to fight with president trump
in essence nobody is really at fault
here
the problem is it's just stopped raining
stuart ramsey sky news mexico